if you are ingesting large amount of
data for analysis or looking to simplify
the development of event-driven
micro-services then you need to check
out cloud pub/sub
[Music]
welcome to pub/sub made easy I'm
Priyanka and in today's episode we will
dive deeper into publishers and see some
configuration and application design
choices you will need to make when
building a real-world publisher
application a publisher application
creates and sends messages to a desired
topic on cloud pub/sub cloud pub/sub
offers at least once message delivery
and best effort ordering to existing
subscribers while publishing messages to
a topic when using JSON over rest the
message data must be base64 encoded the
entire request including one or many
messages must be smaller than 10 MB
after decoding the message payload must
not be empty it must contain either a
non empty data field or at least one
attribute what can you include in the
message itself well here's the message
schema you can embed custom attributes
as metadata in the messages attributes
can be text strings or byte strings a
server generated ID unique within the
topic is returned on the successful
publication of a message if you would
like to see an example of publishing a
message check out the previous episode
all client libraries offer an
asynchronous API where your application
does not have to wait for the actual
publish request to be complete although
synchronous or blocking mode of
operation is supported as well check out
the link in the description below for
the API reference documentation for your
choice of programming language and its
support the first decision you have to
make is how to batch your messages you
can configure the client library to send
multiple messages per request to the
service based on the size of the buffer
or time the client waits for the buffer
to fill batching has the obvious
advantage the larger batch size
increases message throughput which is
the rate of messages sent for CPU
a synchronous client libraries try to
publish multiple batches in parallel for
higher throughput but it also comes at a
cost it introduces latency for
individual messages which are queued in
memory until their corresponding batch
is filled and ready to be sent over the
network to minimize latency batching
should be turned off this is
particularly important for applications
that publish a single message as part of
the request response sequence however
the additional network in computing
overhead may make small batches
preferable you'll have to tune your
system messages can be batched based on
request size in bytes number of messages
and time you can overwrite the default
settings by defining your own here's an
example code in Python where we are
defining batch settings for maximum
bytes latency and messages a caveat here
is that once you override one setting
you should override them all explicitly
now here's how this works on the first
message that you send a new batch is
automatically created with a counter for
every subsequent message if there's
already a valid batch that is still
accepting messages then that batch is
used to drop the new message the batch
is published once sufficient time has
elapsed maximum messages is has reached
or maximum bytes Esmond by default the
batch setting is set to point zero five
seconds now what happens if publishing
fields publishing failures are
automatically retried in some client
libraries
check out the linked documentation to
check the support for the language of
your choice because we're dealing with
requests over a network request failure
is a normal part of life and
understanding retries is essential
client libraries support custom retry
settings here's a snippet with retry
error code received from the publisher
here's a snippet with retry parameters
that include timeouts and delays with
the default settings the main two
parameters to understand are the total
timeout which is how long the
application will keep retrying before
giving up and the initial timer which is
how soon it will start me trying
the total time up depends on the typical
availability of your network the memory
available to your machines and
application-specific considerations
alright so today we learned how to
publish messages in cloud pub/sub
different options including synchronous
asynchronous messages and setting up
batches and custom attributes join us
next time to learn more about setting up
subscriber to receive messages if you
like this video and would like to see
more such content don't forget to Like
and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]